going deep on hbo debuts tuesday night
and you can stream it on hbo max as well
it is the life story of one of
uh our favorites and so uh same with
america quite frankly
he is a super bowl champion four times
over a pro football hall of famer and
part of nfl on fox he's terry bradshaw
back here on the rich eisen show how you
doing terry
hey rich how you doing buddy i went
outside to get my airpods
and uh obviously yeah they're dead
they're dead
so i've got you here okay if you can
hear me i can hear you it sounds great
it sounds great
congrats on this doc i i know you don't
like talking about yourself and uh and i
no i know you seriously i know you don't
i know you you'd rather talk about
anything else other than yourself and so
for you to to to sit down and share so
much um
you know
is pretty cool
so congrats on it it's not thank you
that's very kind of yeah you're welcome
it it it's hard to um
do things like that it's
it has a lot of vainness in it you know
it just
you know i don't want to
you talk about your life one of the the
problems with something like this is
maybe you have to go back and open up
old wounds and
i didn't want to do that i had several i
had alone took me a long time to agree
to do this just
simply because i didn't want to do that
and you know i
i thought this would be a really
um
neat thing and they filmed it at the
clay cooper theater
in branson which really made it fun
and uh
so because that's where i perform i'll
be performing this offseason so it's
good for him good for the show and so
from that standpoint i was really happy
to do it and you're right the rest
sitting down talking talking and opening
up
not exactly something something i enjoy
well i mean people want to know your
story terry and i know you you might you
know you're a humble guy in that respect
but people want to know your story what
are you surprised the most that you
shared
for this documentary that even surprised
you wow i went there i think yeah i
think um
my wife watched it um
eric shanks fox watched it
that's two
i didn't yes
i didn't watch it but
i wouldn't watch it although my wife
said you really don't have to watch it
but just listen to it and so you can
comment on it and i
so we were driving in the car and so she
put it through her
her
phone through the
car speakers and even just she and i
driving it's not yeah
i didn't really like like hearing that
at all so
you know rich i've been in television
40s for years
and you know i've only watched one show
ever
which one is one show what's that and
cbs cbs
made me sit down
and review the very next day after my
first show on nfl today
and uh watched that show and then
critiqued me and tell me dude
that's the only one i've ever watched
have you never seen any of your movies
back terry have you ever seen all the
movies because i quite honestly thought
i was fabulous
the movies the movies were fun yeah
and um
you're you're just playing a character
or trying to you're really yourself
so i didn't have a problem with the
movies and failure to launch heck i got
naked you know i mean naked and i just
got a kick out of that
but
so the movie's not hard the singing
um
i don't know why i'm nervous about
watching myself sing
that's probably uh
because
because i'm not very good maybe that's
why i know that
that might have something to do with it
well it's kind of neat that this
documentary again is the through line is
your show and and um and then everything
else kind of branches off from that and
then the pop culture stuff you know you
we've talked about it before when you've
been on the show
and and i i can't get enough of that you
know the the the story of how you wound
up in burke reynolds movies
is yes amazing can you just dive into
this a little bit here well yeah i'll
give you the short version i did it they
did a skit they used to nbc
this
did a skit the night before super bowl
10
and bert went on there and
it's in the documentary
leave they play it
and basically take shots at me and we go
be in when then it was about the dumb
thing and was it about the dumb thing
i'm not sure maybe
anyway
um
we win the game and he catches all kind
of heck from the pittsburgh stevens fans
for what he did to me and i
i'd started singing and traveling uh
doing country music uh
shows opening for
you know some
for some big stars and then doing my own
and small clubs around the country and
so i was traveling in la and i was doing
the palomino club
and i had two shows there
and uh
his agent david gersherson
delivered huge
bouquet of carnations or something i
don't know what they were but they were
beautiful and a horseshoe shaped
with a letter i'm so sorry
i really like i really like you
i i respect you i can identify with you
the hardships and all and
i wish i had never done that i had i had
i had reservations about doing it
because how much i enjoy watching you as
a player from birmingham
beautiful letter from burt reynolds
and he said
david gershon who ended up being my
manager for
ever he just passed away
um he said bert would like to you if
you've got time tomorrow to come out on
the set he'd like to meet you personally
if you have to fly outside say well i
got a show in albuquerque but i got a
day off and so the band went on and
and uh
i went i stayed over went out to meet uh
bert on the
shoot
of canon and not ken about running the
hooper the yeah the uh stunt movie and
uh i was and so he went out there he
came out of his
trailer and grabbed me and he hugged me
and kissed me on the cheek and told me
how much he loved me and i'm sorry i
mean that's amazing
and so we talked and talked and talked
about everything in the world and
it was put me right at ease being around
such a start
and then he said i gotta have you in
this movie
uh i said i i'm no actor he said
yeah you are too you're an actor you can
do this let's see i want to put you in
this movie he called foul needham and
has him come over and he says i want to
put him in the movie introduce me to him
so
uh they sat on on the top of burke's
truck and they opened up the script and
they wrote me in and they wrote they
wrote me all in the script's okay
um
here's you're going to be this guy from
houston texas
and
would give me a filming date to be there
so i came out
and did uh i did hooper and
and i make believe makeshift we did in
the parking lot actually of the palomino
club and they made it look like the
palomino club and
and so that's my first movie yeah and
then you were in five years and then
you're in five reynolds movies in in
your in your career and evening i did
three evening shades with him and uh
damn all born out of that all born out
of that segment that he did you know
making fun of you and then feeling bad
and then i used to go to his mom and
dad's house in jupiter florida we'd sit
on the porch and drink iced tea then i
would go to his theater with him
uh him and sally fields and um
we just did a lot of cool things
together i don't know he just liked me
you know he just
evening shade with the screen i mean
that was so much fun um he's so much fun
if you ever watch burke's movies
those that he is in control of
you'll always see the same cast of
characters she always says alfie is
always one of these guys a little bitty
shortcut always one of his buddies and
he's always in every movie and
it's just bert he's just loyal terry
bradshaw here on the rich eisen show
hbo's terry bradshaw going deep tuesday
february 1st um at 9 00 pm eastern and
then you could stream it as well on hbo
max so um you know in a couple of
minutes i have left with you here uh
let me ask you a couple current football
uh ben roethlisberger retires
what do you think his legacy is in
pittsburgh i think it's i think it's uh
he would easily uh he owns every record
there is in in the book the only thing
he doesn't have is
two more super bowls to tie my my four
super bowls but outside of that he's got
it all uh he's got everything so i think
he's the top side quarterback in the
league for yardage and touchdowns and
just an amazing amazing career just a
great player before obviously
you know antonio brown and uh le'veon
bell when they all left and those guys
were headed for hall of fame careers
themselves rich but they you know i
understand they went for the money and
their careers went to and then
le'veon just totally disappeared and
brown is just you know i don't know what
his situation is but
it's not good i can tell you that so
but i think he
he had some struggles early off the
field in his life in his career got his
life turned around married a couple of
children and uh
i don't know him rich don't know him
well at all i mean i don't know him at
all i did text him a couple of times
last year
uh text him once this year
congratulating him it's great career
that's it i mean that's pretty much it
you hear about all i have about him do
your best
no not not not this time not not this
year i didn't any very hey listen very
easily could not have gotten it you know
what i mean
and uh
so no big deal
i probably got millions of texas but
uh i didn't lose any sleep over it i
just
you know but i didn't hear back but
that's all right hey rich yes sir that's
all right
so uh but he he deserves to be in the
bus room with you in canton ohio oh
absolutely okay oh sure if you'd asked
me that question i would have said
absolutely
absolutely goes in first ballot listen
before just beat the snot out of him
uh there was none better
i would have taken him over any
quarterback in the league and that
includes a guy down in tampa bay
the young man in tampa bay has been very
blessed and fortunate to have been
surrounded with talent and talent and
talent and ben came in and they all went
out and offensive blind got old got bad
and he got the heck beat out of him for
the last three years
and uh
and we all know he stands in there and
takes a beating
and it has it takes his toll on you and
it took you know took his toll on him
but 18 years is great
what do you think
what do you think this dealer should do
to replace him what do you think you you
can holly rich tell me
i don't think they had the answer on the
bench
mason rudolph rudolph i believed his
name out of oklahoma state to get him in
the second round right he had his
chances and i didn't see much from him
he didn't
you know maybe he just got to have maybe
he has to play a full season
and they
they got to build something around him
look rich i've said this so many times
i'll say it again
i don't care who's playing quarterback
brady ben roethlisberger
um doesn't matter to me the guy in the
homes it doesn't matter if they don't
have talent around them they're not
gonna you're not gonna see their cows if
you don't protect them and give them a
running back and give them a ride wide
receivers where they can function and
their talents show it's not gonna work
it will it will not work for anybody
playing in this game if you don't
surround them with talent and then oh
and by the way it wouldn't be a bad idea
to have some defense too and
i mean that's asking a lot
but why not huh why i mean why not we're
got it we got the rams coming up and
they went out and did everything they
could
to try to
you know put a team together the win
this year with the quarterback the wide
receiver they get acres back i mean
they've got some really cr von miller's
there i mean they've got you know jalen
ramsey they've got some really good
pieces pieces that they went and got
so they surrounded their quarterback
stafford and
their defense and i mean they sold out
it doesn't work then you basically got
you got to start over would you counsel
the steelers to go get rogers
if he's available would you do that
i
i don't think
aaron would go to pittsburgh i think he
had analyzed the offensive lines not
very good
the wide receivers
are hit and miss they have basically no
that tigen's not bad not bad a young kid
out of penn state i believe
i don't think that's something that he's
going to want to be a part of
because he did say he didn't want to be
a part of rebuilding and it very well
could be that's what pittsburgh is going
to have to do is rebuild um
defensively it's probably there though
they've got to fix their offense they've
got to fix it um they got the kid out of
alabama running back just got to get
some linemen in there
i don't know where aaron's going to go
everybody said denver
you know
i don't know i don't know if he's going
to go anywhere he may go back to green
bay which is what i do
i go back where it's loaded they gotta
sign adams and i don't know if they can
sign them both really i don't know we'll
see last one for you terry what do you
think happened sunday when you're uh you
and the rest of the fox squirrel be
together getting ready for
i think kansas city takes care of
cincinnati
and i believe um
i've been riding the 49ers
and i'm going to stay with the 49ers
even though it's hard to win you know
seven in a row
right hey listen today is what friday
can i can i can i change my mind come
sunday morning well i think i think i'll
yeah all my thinking right now has been
i'm not going to turn my back on the
49ers now although i love stafford and
he's a friend of mine
and he'll be upset if i pick the 49ers
but garoppolo's a friend of mine and i
really like jimmy i've always kind of
pulled for jimmy both of these
quarterbacks make mistakes at the wrong
time rich
um
but boy that bunch in san francisco
they're kind of a hard-nosed
blow to your bloodier mouth kind of
bunch i like that i like that a lot so
right now i'm going to go with the 49ers
so well terry you know i i the uh the
afro mentioned uh uh major domo of fox
sports that you mentioned eric shanks
will probably appreciate if you you know
uh if you do change your mind that
there'll be a nice fresh nice fresh um
opinion for for fox on sunday but
you know oh i see a fresh opinion you
know what i'm saying no i'll tell you
what he just may have to take this one
and just keep it there we go in the mean
in the meantime congrats on this doc uh
terry you know i mean this is great
stuff
no seriously like again i i know again
this is not your your your wish to sit
down and talk about yourself but there
are so many people that have come to
know you and feel like they know you
because you are who you are on
television you know i am kind of an open
book you're right i don't have a problem
letting you see inside i think my wife
did it best when she watched it i just
done the show
and i sat down two nights in a row did
the show and sat down and did interviews
and she said
she said i could i see an edge about you
in this interview that's a little bit on
the
angry side
and i said huh that's interesting i
it could be
could be i'm tired of talking about it
it could be i'm all i love to be honest
even though it gets me in trouble
so
you watch it rich you you tell me what
you think i would be more than happy
absolutely right back at you terry
bradshaw okay bud right back at you
thank you for a great man i love your
work buddy right back at you terry let's
make this uh more often i appreciate the
time okay
thank you charge those eyes charge those
air pods terry charge them up i'm
holding them in my hand right now okay
charge them up let's get you know the
championship sunday we can't have this
championship sunday coming up
take care terry all right there we go
terry bradshaw
i just told terry bradshaw to focus
essentially yeah
oh
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here